get our Empire I feel guilty about the
horrible things we've done you know what
we have to do now we've been building
towards an inevitable conclusion we have
to show your downfall no people will be
expecting that true the way I see it
we've got two options lay it out for
shock ending I like it something way out
of left feet like why oh I don't know I
kill you huh okay well uh what's option
two we can have an ambiguous Cliffhanger
isn't that kind of tacky not if we
really play it up make it seem
stylistically bold I don't love either
of these and what do you want it's hard
to have to show in a way that's both
artistically challenging and emotionally
cathartic we aren't one of those cheap
network shows we've won Emmys we have
two options why not both that would be
too much okay that that I'm pregnant
father is the ghost of your dead dad I
killed your father I'm pregnant I'm
pregnant
[Applause]